this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this Frank Rossi i'm at the bethpage
state park here in late april of 2011
and i'm looking over the greens here and
noticing one of the first things I'm
noticing is the sort of yellowing that
we get from that early proxy primo
application you look real closely at the
putting surfaces and you notice that you
really see the dramatic differences
between the bent grass and the annual
bluegrass the annual bluegrass that sort
of flash of yellowing that you get from
the proxy application for seed has
depression and then at this time of year
it's very common that the bank grass
will just be very slow to go it's much
late starter and so you'll see the real
differentiation between the two growth
habits at this point the other thing you
notice at the springtime that I've
noticed consistently is where we've done
the sodding work around bunkers are
around green surrounds to replace the
blue grass sod we've consistently
replaced it with sort of low grow tight
Kentucky bluegrass or the elite types of
Kentucky bluegrass that that we use in
sod production and one of the things we
notice about that is that it's very slow
to green up in the springtime and so you
can really get a good example of sort of
why if you need really good spring
quality turf why some of these low grow
elite varieties may not be the most
ideal for most situations we're looking
forward to a great growing season here
at bethpage and hope you follow along
with us all year this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu